salut les amis on est ensemble pendant
deux heures ce soir allez-y messieurs
les dames ne vous arrêtez surtout pas
pour nous c'est oui on est en direct
dans Paris on est devant le Théâtre de
la Madeleine parce que Philippe
Lellouche joue une pièce il est encore
en train de jouer on va rentrer parce
que on nous attend le directeur du
théâtre nous attend vous n'hésitez pas à
vous réagissez tout au long de la soirée
sur Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube on va aller
à plein de mon endroit on va vous
montrer plein de choses regardez c'est
cette pièce et je demande à Sylvain de
me suivre c'est lui qui va filmer toute
la toute la soirée ça s'appelle le
tourbillon c'est mise en scène par
Francis Veber avec Philippe Lellouche
avec Catherine Amorino notamment on va
passer la soirée avec elle également
du théâtre et on va tout vous montrer
alors on y va je tiens j'ai 24 heures
ici évidemment
le directeur nous attend Michel bonjour
Comment ça va ça va et vous merci de
nous accueillir
au Théâtre de la Madeleine vous êtes
directeur évidemment du théâtre
producteur une pièce sympa Francis Veber
c'est pas rien faire c'est le top du top
le dîner de cons surtout avant avant le
tourbillon maintenant oui et puis on a
fait beaucoup d'autres et puis il a fait
je crois 30 31 films 31 films que des
que des succès que des que des comédies
extraordinaires bon il est 22h16 la
pièce se termine à quelle heure à peu
près généralement a priori aujourd'hui
ça va être dans cinq six minutes ne
faites faire un petit tour et puis après
vous nous avez derrière comme ça on
récupère Philippe à ce moment-là vous
voulez voir quoi je sais pas c'est chez
vous qu'est-ce qu'il faut voir ici
le foyer est pas allumé je pense
1924 1924
pièces ici 24 ou 25 pièces alors
beaucoup de théâtres parisiens se
vantent aussi d'avoir eu Guy puisque il
en a fait un paquet et
en fait
ici il a il a beaucoup beaucoup
créé et jouer d'accord et c'est un très
beau théâtre qui a un peu plus de 700
places
et où les gens sont très bien assis il y
a une très belle visibilité
on a tous les artistes adorent venir
jouer ici bon là on est dans les loges
des Loges on est dans la coursive où on
stocke je sais pas s'il y a des décors
en ce moment il y en a là-bas mais
cacher
mais on a tout aménagé pour stocker des
décors qu'on colle sur les murs qu'on
plaque au mur la scène est où la scène
est tout au bout
là ici c'est le petit atelier d'urgence
en pleine pièce on peut faire un truc
oui juste avant juste avant oui entre
deux pièces en fait ici c'est là où on
passe les décors et là on donne sur la
scène c'est le début de la scène c'est
ici est-ce qu'on peut on entend oui on
va faire le tour on va faire le tour
j'entends que ça joue
pas c'est ça la magie évidemment
mais c'est marqué quand même silence si
on a on peut aller tout en dessous
peut-être qu'on ira tout à l'heure si on
a 5 minutes mais là il y a des il y a
des choses très drôles à voir
et donc là ici on arrive derrière le
plateau donc là c'est la
loge d'urgence c'est-à-dire avec
l'arrivée pour l'incendie
Michel on est ensemble pendant deux
heures ce soir on suit Philippe
Lellouche mais Philippe Lellouche est
encore en train de jouer oui voilà il
faut le préciser il joue quand le
mercredi du mercredi au dimanche voilà
donc
où est-ce qu'on va où est-ce que vous
nous emmener et à partir de maintenant
on va parler plus doucement d'accord
allez-y je vous laisse aller et Sylvain
vous suit comme ça
on ira tout à l'heure là c'est la scène
en attendant
mais si c'est ça
mérino mais c'est là comme c'est une
loge de femme on fait plus attention
même si maintenant il y a l'égalité
il paraît qu'il faut rentrer là
donc là ici elle a une histoire cette
loge c'est la loge justement que se
garder Sacha Guitry qu'il joue ou pas il
était ici donc c'est le seul endroit du
théâtre qu'on a pas repeint ses
chaussures très le même genre de
chaussures que Philippe mais c'est en
tout cas
il y a qu'un rajout
c'est lorsque on a fait le limier ici et
c'est Patrick Bruel qui a demandé
d'avoir sa douche dans la loge qui
n'avait pas Sacha guitare
à l'époque on se lavait
je vois là haut il y a
que entre deux
moments où il est pas sur scène et bien
ici où il reste là ça dépend des pièces
ça dépend des pièces là dans celle-là il
a pas le temps il sort et il reste sur
le sur le côté mais sur certains sur
certains projets ou certaines dans
certains scènes et dans certaines pièces
pardon les comédiens qui démarrent un
peu plus tard 10 minutes après le fameux
d'après sont ici elles sont en attente
et ils ont de retour ils sont là vous
connaissez bien la pièce vous en êtes où
là à peu près
c'est bientôt la fin
[Musique]
non tu peux pas faire ça
oui je comprends
oui je comprends la rentrée oui je
comprends je comprends Laurent
un petit peu
[Musique]
exactement quand on regarde la scène
Jésus
à gauche ou à droite
de poids
bonsoir vous êtes
marié
dessin après les autres et des animaux
entre les deux entre les scènes
est-ce qu'on peut voir la loge de
Katerina ou c'est une loge un peu
stricte
c'est une star en Italie c'est une star
aux États-Unis
nous fait l'honneur de jouer avec nous
c'est gentil merci beaucoup
on monte à chaque fois parce que
derrière il y a plus de place
ça c'est notre prochain projet
c'est écrit par un
c'est une pièce de jam perle Marinelli
et d'italien
on peut rien on va la jouer ici et en
Italie avec donc Christophe Barbier sur
scène
on peut aller par ici
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
va nous rejoindre une sorte tout juste
de scène du tourbillon c'est une pièce
de Francis Veber au Théâtre de la
Madeleine on va essayer de l'attraper au
volant qui sont là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on essaie de trouver Philippe
Lellouche allez on y va
bonsoir
et en fait Michel il faut absolument
virer Adrien
genre moi aussi je fais
une réplique il fait moi aussi j'ai fait
caca
j'ai raté mon coup je voulais les piéger
tu sais parce que tous les soirs je fais
un truc différent sur la mode et je
voulais et je voulais et je vous le dis
j'ai mis sur le téléphone les perles les
trucs relous là les percussions là
génial ça va pas trop transpirant ça va
non ça va bon on va pouvoir enchaîner
alors on va pouvoir s'habiller on a déjà
il y avait rien de compromettant
ça s'est bien passé
on n'est pas très sérieux mais on peut
se permettre j'ai vu que vous vous
permettiez et j'ai la confirmation de
sortir un peu du texte parfois un peu
ouais juste pour faire rire les copains
[Musique]
alors je voudrais on est en direct
je vous présente le producteur qui
s'appelle Michel landau pour nous
présentons
qui dans mon portable et depuis à peu
près 12 ans Benjamin Caouette qui ne
veut absolument rien dire Benjamin
Guinois qui est qui est le bras droit de
Michel et notre producteur associé quoi
en gros et puis bon bah la troupe Adrien
raka bonjour plus connu comme moteur
et compte tenu de ce qui fait en ce
moment je pense que ça c'est une
carrière qui sera éphémère
au début de au début
au début des répétitions qui disaient si
vous avez une prise de foire
reposez-vous sur moi je suis une barre
de fer elle rit les choix
elle a un peu je rigole non mais tu as
rigolé au départ
j'ai demandé à Michel de venir pour
faire un rapport je vous ai vu hier non
hier vous étiez impeccable vous êtes
fait mal au dos vous avez un peu plus
fort
il faut acheter un nouveau canapé
de la prochaine pièce qui est arrivé
sur Youtube en direct exactement c'est
fou non mais tout à fait alors on pourra
même répondre à leurs questions et tout
c'est vrai
on explique un peu où on va après alors
on va on va se changer après on va
rejoindre les autres camarades l'autre
pièce qui a écrit tadrien qui s'appelle
l'invitation que j'ai joué avec Gad
Elmaleh il y a quelques temps et qui a
joué maintenant par Patrick Chesnais
parce qu'elle Légitimus et du sigène
elle était avec nous et jouer au bouffe
parisien on va voir comment ça s'est
passé et après on va bouffer parce qu'on
traitement
vous nous montre pas tout de suite alors
je me change et j'arrive
on trouve une solution pour pas vous
filmer
alors ouais c'était parce qu'il faut le
dire vous êtes pas que comédien ici non
je suis le directeur artistique du
théâtre
donc j'ai en charge la programmation de
ce merveilleux théâtre et cette loge
c'est à part la douche que Patrick Bruel
a fait de construire
c'est c'est la loge dans l'état de
de Guy quoi il a joué ici 22 pièces à
chaque Guitry c'est pas rien ça fait
rêver c'est à dire qu'on a une carrière
de merde
oui c'est vrai quand on se compare mais
pas là
c'est sûr bon et qui d'autre ici
la 8e année c'est la huitième année
c'est toujours un plaisir enfin je suis
très très attaché à ce thé à très
évident je commence à le connaître un
peu par coeur je ouais je suis vraiment
très heureux de diriger ce théâtre c'est
c'est en fait c'est c'est tout d'un coup
une fonction sérieuse
là maintenant il y a d'autres enjeux
notre métier c'est de faire très
sérieusement des choses pas sérieuses en
réalité voilà mais ça ça prend de
sérieux parce que ça ça a vécu avant
nous et ça vivra bien après et donc
d'essayer de de voilà de se dire je fais
partie de maintenant de l'histoire de
théâtre il y a un truc très rassurant
peut-être
on tire le rideau mais vous continuez à
nous parler et de Francis Weber on est
obligé de parler de Francis
[Rires]
si je me mettais mais le micro je suis
obligé de le bazar mais alors on va vous
le changer mais gardez la portée de main
bon et alors Francis Veber comment ça
s'est fait cette pièce bah ça s'est fait
que moi cette année je voulais pas trop
jouer au théâtre c'était c'est Michel
Lumbroso qui est à côté de vous qui un
jour m'a dit écoute je sais que cette
année tu veux faire off avec tu veux
faire d'autres trucs mais ça marche pas
du tout ces rideaux c'est complètement
on n'a pas la caméra dessus
moi je vois le caleçon il est superbe
donc
maladies il y a quand même Francis Weber
qui a envie de te faire jouer tu devrais
le rencontrer bon ben là c'était me
piéger parce qu'évidemment quand on
rentre on rencontre Francis Weber qui a
autant de chef-d'oeuvre à son actif et
que le mec vous fait des compliments
sublimes sur votre jeu et sur l'envie
qu'il a travaillé avec vous c'est un
refusable donc donc on a plongé j'ai
plongé et je le regrette pas d'ailleurs
mais je vous connais je vous connais pas
pas encore on va mieux se connaître dans
deux heures vous avez quand même bien le
profil de à jouer les comptes Francis
Weber quand même je suis pas sûr que ce
soit un compliment ça mais en tout cas
en tout cas c'est vous pouvez pas me
faire plus plaisir j'ai il m'a dit t'as
pas le profil d'un pignon mais d'un
Campana Campana
Campana c'est un peu la brute épaisse
voilà qui est pas
là c'était Depardieu dans la chaîne
et donc pignon c'est plus c'est plus sa
faible pignon c'est plus un mec qui est
une victime Campana c'est c'est
Villeret ou Brel exactement où ouais
ouais c'est ça donc évidemment ça se
refuse pas enfin voilà il y a des mecs
comme ça qui sont des légendes avec
lesquelles on a grandi c'est-à-dire que
dans l'humour en fait il y a qui il y a
Dabadie voilà il y avait malheureusement
disparu Jean-Loup que j'adorais il y
avait Audiard il y avait Yves Robert en
France je parle dans l'ancienne
génération et Francis Weber donc le type
quand il vous dit
j'ai envie de travailler avec vous c'est
pas en fait c'est par fusable alors si
on peut tout refuser mais bon c'est
bizarre quoi ça fait partie vous avez
changé le t-shirt ou pas ou c'est fini
non pas du tout ah bon c'est bon on peut
récupérer Philippe Lellouche non pas
encore j'ai pas enlevé le t-shirt
vous êtes un précoce
je vous ai provoqué sur sur le compte
Weber vous me provoquer des heures
non non c'est parce que il habite pas en
France c'est ça non il habite à Los
Angeles il a gagné un peu de pognon qui
vit avec Los Angeles il a il a une très
belle maison dans le sud de la France il
a il a un peu des résidences partout
mais ça fait quelques années qu'il a
vraiment qui vit là-bas quoi donc c'est
c'est très marrant mais mais il continue
à être complètement
tu vois attentif à ce qui se passe en
France et à ce qui marche qui marche pas
il est encore dans le coup quoi voilà
donc c'est pour ça que c'est c'était
chouette alors là il est venu évidemment
tout le mois de septembre pour les
répétitions et puis là il suit de loin
il appelle de t'entendre disons comment
ça marche les garçons les filles et vous
êtes heureux tout ça donc c'est chouette
et il a toujours l'ambition parce que ce
qui fait souvent c'est une pièce et puis
après il en fait un film ouais
on sait pas ça oui lui il dit qu'il a
qu'il a envie de faire le film à un
moment ou un autre mais j'ai Philippe
lelouf torse nu je vous le dis ne soyez
pas déçus
il doit y avoir des millions de
malheureux pas voir ce soir et c'est
vrai
ça dépend de vous c'est vous allez
voir
non mais bon
ça dépend on peut monter à 10 15000
jusqu'à 50 vous savez on peut aller ah
si on peut
qui a le record pour l'instant avec ces
Michalik
mais vous pouvez le battre
est-ce que vous avez le micro
[Musique]
non mais je me rapproche il est où ce
micro
on va le remettre
donc Weber vous appelle et alors après
comment ça se fait le casting alors
après le casting il se fait il se fait
bah c'est le metteur en scène qui
choisit il a eu la gentillesse de me
demander si
si j'avais envie de jouer avec Caterina
avec
si vous avez parfait
même si elle est formidable dedans Aline
Gayo que je connaissais assez peu c'est
Francis qui l'a rencontré d'accord et
ça veut dire quoi c'est tous les acteurs
l'ont pas espèce de mystère de la
comédie tu sais comment faire rire
c'est-à-dire que tu as le sens naturel
tu sais naturellement c'est la vie comme
Ikea c'est un truc très particulier
c'est c'est voilà c'est presque un ouais
je pense que c'est un petit supplément
de jeu où tu sais
pas force pas nécessairement mais en
tout cas tu connais la rythmique du
comics
on y va comment en bagnole non bon bah
d'accord vous montez avec moi je monte
avec vous allez super conduisait
tranquillement non vous savez que c'est
limité à 30 km/h on pourra pas les tenir
j'attendais ce moment mais je voulais
attendre d'être dans la voiture ah bah
on va on va en parler allez on y va
c'est parti on passe par là la scène non
on passe par là non non non
c'est en train de se changer alors je
vais regarder si vous êtes nombreux sur
Youtube ou Le Figaro.fr on va essayer de
trouver ça on a dit qu'on pouvait passer
par la scène alors on peut passer par la
scène alors en passant par la scène
c'est quand même pas mal c'est un beau
théâtre ah bah [ __ ] s'il est beau
Jean-Marc Renaud des techniciens
intermittents qui prennent 12000 euros
par mois faut savoir que dans ce théâtre
ils prennent ils sont 12000 euros c'est
Michel qui les payent parce qu'il
planque beaucoup de pognon aux impôts
par l'étranger il arrive à payer très
bien son personnel pour qu'il reste bon
c'est des trucs chacun se démerde comme
il veut sans dépression
à demain les garçons merci beaucoup
Michel
on y va allez c'est parti et on suit
vous me suivez
c'est beau c'est beau alors je vais vous
raconter un truc mais on va se faire
engueuler mais je vais faire vite c'est
pas grave on a tout la première année où
j'ai pris la direction de ce théâtre on
répétait avec Darmon
et on entendait des strapontins se lever
et on disait mais [ __ ] on est en
répète l'après-midi on se dit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe il y a du monde
là-haut il y a personne et j'appelle le
directeur technique qui est parti depuis
qui est pris sa retraite et juillet on
entend des straps midi c'est bizarre
parce que le théâtre personne n'a joué
tu sais des fois les straps reste
coincés voilà et ça remonte mais il dit
la personne à jouer depuis 8 mois et
tous les jours on entendait ça et puis
un jour il y a la dame qui fait le
ménage ici tu dis mais ça c'est le
fantôme d'ici
très sérieusement elle nous dit ça et je
dis mais comment ça le fantôme je suis
un peu une flipette sur ces trucs là je
la ramène pas elle me dit ouais et elle
me raconte cette histoire que je vous
jure est vrai c'est enfin en tout cas
elle me l'a vraiment dit je vois pas
pourquoi elle ment en fait elle arrive
tous les matins pour faire le ménage
d'accord donc le théâtre est fermé et un
matin elle est arrivée par cette force
cette porte elle a vu en monsieur au
troisième mandat donc elle était en
panique elle a dit mais qu'est-ce que
vous faites là Monsieur et il paraît que
le type s'est retourné a dit mais vous
me voyez
elle a dit bah oui elle a fait comme ça
avec la tête le mec a disparu je te
laisse dormir avec ça mais c'est une
vraie histoire c'est pas vrai
alors il semblerait que tous les
théâtres ont une vraie histoire ils sont
toujours habités c'est ce qu'on dit dans
les théâtres c'est pour ça que vous
aimez le théâtre c'est pour ça que
j'aime tant le théâtre en tout cas c'est
très flippant c'est flippant
[Musique]
[Rires]
allez go allez on est parti
regardez je vous montre quand même
on est en direct bon il y a un petit
décalage mais on y est ça c'est
incroyable finalement
on monte dans le bolide alors on monte
dans le bolide
je monte derrière Sylvain passe devant
allez
ah ouais il fait un peu de bruit
celle-là ouais elle est un peu c'est un
peu une
c'est un peu une voiture de pompette
donc là on monte quand même dans la dans
la bagnole
du mec qui fait top Gears
quand tu fais te le dire c'est quand les
gens de voient avec une chouette de
voiture ils ont pas envie de te larguer
tu vois
c'est quoi ça
c'est le Range Rover SVR
c'est à dire que ça arrange Rover le
Range Sport le plus sport qui soit parce
qu'il y a un peu plus de 650 chevaux ah
oui mais alors c'est frustrant ici et
vous avez vu je vous ramène un Hidalgo
c'est frustrant ici non mais c'est
frustrant là c'est pas une Hidalgo parce
que là c'est frustrant tout simplement
parce que faut être faut faire hyper
gaffe moi je dis toujours que ce qu'on
fait dans le Top Gear on le fait
tellement bien encadrer que c'est pas
dangereux tu vois émis c'est dangereux
c'est dangereux que pour nous les mecs
qui roulent vite en ville etc sont juste
des des dangers publics donc moi ça je
défends pas ça puisque si tu veux que
j'attaque Hidalgo je l'attaquerai sur
autre chose c'est sur la façon dont elle
a étouffée Paris et qui viennent
considérablement le théâtre les
restaurants etc bah parce que quand les
gens qui font vivre le théâtre et les
restaurants et les lieux de voilà c'est
pas que les Parisiens c'est aussi la
petite et grande couronne d'accord
et puis ils viennent pendant les
vacances mais la petite est la grande
couronne qui fait le théâtre et les
restaurants quand ils ont mis une heure
et demie pour rentrer chez eux le soir
elles ont pas envie de se les retaper
dans l'autre sens si tu rajoutes à ça la
possibilité de te garer l'impossible le
prix du parking le prix du resto le prix
du théâtre ta soirée elle est tellement
chère que voilà donc en fait on a elle a
asphyxié tout ce qui comptait de culture
à Paris d'ailleurs c'est devenu si tu
regardes bien il y a Paris la nuit toi
qui tourne tous les soirs tu trouves
qu'il y a 2000 endroits où aller non
c'est vrai voilà c'est vrai donc si tu
veux
peut-être le moment pardon vieux con
mais pourquoi c'était mieux avant Paris
la nuit ah bah non mais c'est alors là
les gars
regarde juste sans ton prédécesseur dans
le genre de programme qui était tiré
Ardisson ok regarde dans un joli
compliment enfin je sais pas si simple
c'est le génie de la télé regarde tous
les endroits où il allait la nuit
aujourd'hui quand on sort du théâtre à
23 heures on est en carafe pour aller
vous faire en disant où est-ce qu'on va
c'est pas il n'y a pas pléthore de resto
et de couvert
en tout cas c'est plus le pari
évidemment que on a connu mais c'est pas
grave c'est en état d'autre c'est un
pari de bureau et de bouchons et de et
de plots en plastique jaune tu as pas
remarqué que dans toutes les rues de
Paris tu as des plans en plastique jaune
voilà mais ça c'est pour les vélos
j'imagine c'est vraiment si tu veux
faire du vélo
quoi allez donc les mecs qui veulent
absolument respirer dans Paris c'est
irrespirable voilà les habitants à la
campagne les gars tout sera moins cher
et en plus elle a augmenté 40 % les
ampoules locaux vraiment c'était une
bonne opération je suis content parce
que je me suis dit il va se faire
Hidalgo je vais avoir une bonne séquence
vous l'avez fait quoi non mais je me la
fais pas pour le plaisir de me faire
c'est à dire que dans la vie je ne doute
pas que ce soit une femme charmante et
très agréable ce serait bien que vous la
faire rencontrer mais c'est mais vous
l'avez peut-être déjà rencontré
d'ailleurs ouais je l'ai rencontré on
évite de se parler je crois
copieusement mais mais on peut pas on
peut pas être on peut pas être tout le
temps politiquement correct et tout le
temps dire du bien des gens quand on les
pense quand on le pense pas tu vois et
moi je te dis humainement j'ai
évidemment que je connais pas cette dame
et peut-être ça sera une très bonne
copine en tant que mère je lui en veux
beaucoup d'avoir bousillé ma ville la
ville dans laquelle on travaille mais
pas pour moi perso parce que je suis un
nostalgique des années 80 comme un vieux
crétin c'est juste parce que je vois
bien que ça fonctionne plus voilà qui a
que que les gens se tapent dessus pour
une place de parking que les vélos
détestaient scooter qui eux-mêmes
détestent les trottinettes qui eux-mêmes
détestent les taxis qui eux-mêmes
détestent les bus voilà regarde c'est ça
c'est l'exemple tu vois on est avenue de
l'Opéra et voilà mais ça c'est tout le
temps et partout je lis quand même parce
que vous étonnez Félix qui nous dit quel
plaisir dans le siècle que nous vivons
vous voyez lui il est content d'avoir
cette accessibilité à suivre des acteurs
comédiens de renom par le biais de média
voilà bah ça c'est cool je l'embrasse le
Félix LTV j'ai eu la chance de voir deux
pièces de file de Philippe à Biarritz le
jeu de la vérité voir fumé et conduire
vite c'était deux purs moments de
bonheur voilà ce qui
je pense que c'est je pense que c'est un
coup de peau je pense qu'en fait c'est
comment ça se fait à la base alors moi
je vais te dire comment ça s'est fait
c'est qu'avec mon ex-femme un jour on a
effectué turbo parce qu'elle elle rêvait
de la Renault Espace bon on me demande
pas pourquoi des fois on peut se marier
c'est pas vrai les mêmes habits surtout
donc et quand moi j'ai fait turbo ce
jour là j'ai dit mais comment tu peux
aimer cette merde etc et en rigolant
quoi parce que en fait j'étais pas du
tout dans la séquence j'étais avec elle
dans la séquence et je crois que la BBC
et les mecs de Top Gear ont vu cette
séquence et qui sont dit il faut qu'un
mec qui
parle comme ça l'origine c'est un c'est
quoi c'est les Anglais qui veulent faire
tablier en France c'est pas ah non bien
sûr c'est la BBC qui le fait dans le
monde entier qu'il décline dans le monde
entier avec trois animateurs
à l'époque qui était fait par Jérémy
Clarkson et deux autres qui un programme
qui est le plus vu dans le monde qui
faisait des millions de victoires
anglais mais vu dans le monde entier et
petit ils ont eu l'idée de le décliner
dans différents
politiquement correct ça c'est sûr mais
c'est la question qu'on se pose si tu
veux en ce moment c'est dire à l'heure
où il est question que la voiture
disparaisse dans une dizaine d'années
est-ce que ça vaut encore le coup de
faire Top Gear c'est un peu si on refait
une saison de Top Gear parce que c'est
dans les tuyaux ce sera cet axe là c'est
de se dire est-ce que tu aimes dire
encore une raison d'exister voilà mais
c'est la dernière émission tu vois c'est
une émission formidable à faire parce
que
ces trois mecs qui ont 12 ans d'âge
mental tu vois à qui on donne des
voitures elles ont faites ce que vous
voulez donc ça c'est si tu veux c'est un
peu de les casser plus que d'aller
en tout cas c'est de c'est presque une
un bureau de vérification de la
publicité tu vois par exemple je me
souviens qu'on nous avait dit si la Clio
a jamais été aussi grande ben j'avais
été au Moulin Rouge dans un combien de
danseuses du Moulin Rouge on peut faire
rentrer dans une Clio tu vois à chaque
fois prendre le côté
[Musique]
incassable on avait dit bon on va voir
si elle est incassable là oui là on va
tout faire pour la péter et on va voir
combien de temps elle résiste tu vois
mais c'est extrêmement drôle à faire
avec celle-là pour voir combien de temps
la résiste
on peut on peut toujours ça dépend du
chèque allez venez les garçons on est au
restaurant là on arrive au théâtre venez
alors voilà ça c'est donc la pièce que
j'ai joué avec Gad Elmaleh donc c'est
une pièce d'Adrien avec ça alors là
carton
bah oui c'était ça a été phénoménal et
donc c'est une pièce d'Adrien à la base
elle est faite à la Madeleine
là c'était là c'était Philippe Lellouche
et Lucie jeanne est resté la même et là
on a remplacé par deux comédiens et
quand même loin de là et c'est la preuve
que quand une pièce est une bonne pièce
et ben elle peut marcher contre vents et
marée et ils font un carton absolu voilà
et c'est toujours c'est toujours chiant
parce que j'adorerais aller les voir
avec Gad on s'est dit qu'on adorait
aller les voir mais on joue à la même
heure on joue pareil donc on n'arrive
pas à les voir enfin moi je les ai mis
en scène donc on peut les voir ailleurs
on peut on les verra voilà ils sont là
je crois venez viens dès au bouffe
et bonsoir
toi François et toi
alors je vous présente d'abord Laurent
qui est un peu le bonjour Laurent
de ce théâtre qui connaissait théâtre
comme ça poche et qui a un super tété
quoi ce qu'on appelle
tout voilà
il sait faire et là on arrive voir les
artistes
et bonsoir
mais il est là où il y a même des
copains
[Musique]
les présentations
bonjour Lucie Jeanne parce qu'elle
Légitimus un inconnu fallait que je le
fasse
pas bien vous ratez jamais j'aurais aimé
dire que ça se passe
si je puis dire mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est de trouver
autre chose tout en étant pareil il fait
autre chose
à 15 acteurs différents voilà c'est ça
même la jouissance du théâtre
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des gens qui ont
pu venir nous voir avec Gad Lucie et moi
et qui reviennent là qui vont le même
spectacle mais autrement c'est ça qui
est génial d'ailleurs partition c'est
comme une pièce
musicale de Beethoven il y a un chef
d'orchestre qui va donner une attention
vibratoire différente une intention qui
est personnelle donc c'est des autres
comme ça que comme h Shakespeare jouait
1000 fois depuis 300 ans et on continue
à le voir
de comparer à Shakespeare et Beethoven
c'est Adrien
il est super bon dans les deux mais
c'est vrai que c'est lui l'auteur de
cette pièce et je suis pas peu fier
parce que quand je l'ai trouvé cette
pièce personne voulait la jouer voilà
donc
on se connaît depuis
pas loin de 20 ans avec lui aussi et
donc c'est vous qui décidez à ce
moment-là comment ça se passe
au niveau à côté quoi en fait c'est
c'est l'histoire de cette pièce est
hyper belle c'est à dire que un jour je
découvre Adrien RACA qui était pas du
tout enfin connu de son père et sa mère
comme beaucoup de d'artistes avant
d'être célèbre et qui m'amène cette
pièce en disant en faisant de très beaux
compliments sur mon travail en disant
j'adorais travailler avec vous il me
fait dire ce truc là et je tombe
amoureux et je ne pense pas du tout il y
a trois quatre ans
et je pense pas du tout la jouer mais
quand je te dis pas du tout c'est pas du
tout et la première lecture
on va trouver des gens tu vas la jouer
alors elle est superbe sur scène voilà
j'ai compris
donc je l'envoie à plusieurs acteurs qui
la refusent tous tous tous vraiment
[Musique]
il y a plein de il y a plein de raisons
et un jour je je dis Agad écoute tu veux
pas qu'on produise ensemble cette pièce
là parce que il me dit mais ouais
pourquoi pas
je pense même pas et il me dit mais qui
tu voudrais en mettant enceinte puis au
bout d'un moment il me dit ben attends
on va faire simple viens on fait une
lecture chez toi demain et puis comme ça
on sera vraiment de quoi on parle et le
lendemain on fait la lecture et quand il
a fermé le script il m'a dit bon tous
les deux
ça s'est décidé comme ça il m'a dit tu
connais une comédienne et j'en connais
une qui serait formidable pour jouer
avec nous il m'a dit pas casse-couille
je suis super pas casse-couille dit je
dis je suis très jolie bonne comédienne
bonne comédienne et ben vas-y Lucie
voilà et Lucie n'a pas refusé mais
[Rires]
mais j'ai vu que vous étiez maintenant
sur TF1 vous avez faim
non mais certainement pas mes parents
sont ravis
c'est quoi la suite du programme Les
Inconnus Je crois que vous jouez un film
là
de l'intérieur et ensuite il y a un film
l'année prochaine pour l'instant c'est
ça dans les tuyaux c'est quoi ce film
c'est ça dans les tuyaux
quand même avec j'adore l'émission de
télé en live mais j'ai envie j'ai envie
de bouffer
j'ai un anniversaire
[Musique]
c'est pas grave
expliquer ce que c'est parce que ceux
qui nous regardent ne savent peut-être
pas le café joyeux c'est un monsieur qui
a inventé
et donc le patron qui est un ami ce soir
fait un truc un peu private dans un
avenue Foch dans un immeuble avec tous
les personnes qui m'ont aidé et comme je
suis pas un des cafés joyeux
c'est-à-dire que il faut que je te dise
salut mon Lolo merci pour ton accueil
j'espère
31 et vous voilà tu as compris merci
infiniment merci beaucoup monsieur ouais
alors voilà c'est vrai qu'on a juste à
traverser pour bouffer c'est un McDo
normalement j'ai McDo quoi non non
italien de Paris franchement bah tu vas
voir c'est toujours comme quand on
raconte une blague vous voulez faites
bien on dit pas une blague j'ai une
blague c'est la meilleure du monde non
mais celle-là tu vas voir
je vais vous présenter le patron et tout
vient des viander rentrer
pas trop on est beaucoup plus que ça
bonjour
je vous présente Figaro live on est en
direct à la télévision là et je vous
présente le patron donc de ce que je
pense être le meilleur restaurant
italien de Paris il faut pas nous
décevoir maintenant non non mais tu
seras pas déçu tu vas voir et je l'adore
et je l'embrasse
alors combien vous êtes parce que moi on
va manger à 4 à 5 on mange à 5 il y en a
d'autres à côté quoi on se réunira après
ça va et toi tu peux regarder c'est en
direct sur YouTube si tu regardes sur
Youtube ça en direct
ça s'appelle comment le Figaro la nuit
Le Figaro la nuit tu vas voir ça en
direct c'est très simple bonsoir ça va
bien merci merci
ah bah très bien très bien c'est parfait
ok super bonjour
merci beaucoup
on se met où aller
en plus c'est le restaurant préféré de
ma fille Charlie donc donc dès qu'elle
arrive en week-end chez son papa elle me
dit on va à l'italien papa voilà donc
mais au-delà de ça vraiment sans blague
c'est vraiment je me mets ici
en attendant que les autres arrivent RMC
découverte
technique comme on est plus nombreux
on est cinq tu viens
mais il faut construire
Adrien et venez
d'accord mais on se rejoint après parce
qu'il reste pas toute la nuit bien sûr
ils ont des femmes des enfants tout ça
mais tu restes quand même
et toi ben aussi tu te barres
quand même bon avant qu'ils nous
rejoigne je veux parler RMC
ça c'est mal fini
ah c'est une question piège non non non
tu parles de l'émission de radio
c'est arrêté parce que en fait c'était
l'année des élections et le directeur
d'antenne m'a dit
Philippe l'année prochaine on fait du
tout info donc mon émission qui était
finalement un peu la seule
divertissement pure parce que les autres
c'est du divertissement avec du football
les hôtels de l'info ils ont dit ça n'a
plus lieu d'être sur la grille si
j'avais été viré il m'aurait viré aussi
des RMC découverte etc et il y a une une
nana qui m'en voulait un peu je crois
vous avez dit
vous avez dit les féministes c'est que
des moches ah oui non
j'ai pas dit ça non c'est pas du tout ça
j'ai jamais dit ça je crois pas vous
trouveriez ça quelque chose un raccourci
peut-être ah ouais non mais dites-moi
j'ai dit un jour à l'antenne que Sabrina
qui chantait boys boys boys était plus
connu pour ses 5 pour sa musique
globalement celui qui va me dire le
contraire est un menteur voilà et ça ça
n'avait pas plu à une nana du syndicat
qui avait dit c'est des propos sexistes
je l'ai un petit peu envoyé chier et
donc elle s'est vengée quand j'ai dessus
parti des RMC en disant il a été viré ce
qu'il faut c'est une c'est totalement
faux voilà il est pas sexiste
je respecte profondément et je suis pas
là pour dire les choses j'ai des choses
à dire de méchants de Philippe je
voulais dire avec moi c'est
pas bien sûr tu dis tout ce que tu veux
ma chérie
fais gaffe à Philippe parce que drague
tout ce qui bouge je sais pas du tout
vrai alors là je peux dire c'est que des
conneries alors je sais pas si c'est la
jalousie aussi des bêtises mais alors là
c'est pas du tout vrai et c'est au-delà
du excellent acteur mettant en scène qui
au connaît c'est un homme extrêmement
respectueux et qu'il a jamais mis bouger
en oreille on est deux filles et on peut
vraiment dire la vérité sur le coup tout
ça donc sincèrement
malheureusement
si vous aviez voulu
raison mais mais non non mais ça c'était
c'était vraiment ça c'est vraiment de la
c'est du truc auquel si tu remarques
bien quand on a dit ça quand c'est sorti
quand la fille a fait sortir ça a été
viré j'ai même pas réagi c'est à dire
que la réponse elle était évidente non
seulement je continuais RMC découverte
avec Top Gear mais en plus il m'avait
donné une nouvelle émission qui était en
charge mécanique mais il y a un moment
où il faut choisir ses combats voilà
donc
vous dites pas tiens je suis en train de
très important c'est de dire si ce qu'on
pense et raisonnable si on commence à
penser que Hitler est un mec très bien
vaut mieux fermer sa gueule quoi mais tu
doutes bien que je suis loin de penser
ça donc quand on pense des choses qui
restent raisonnables là au contraire
faut les dire et pouvoir s'en expliquer
ce qui est très très important
aujourd'hui c'est la nuance et
aujourd'hui quand tu dis quelque chose
si c'est sorti de son contexte ça peut
t'emmener très loin mais si tu prends le
temps d'expliquer aux gens les gens sont
pas idiots si tu prends le temps de leur
expliquer que ta pensée elle est
celle-là mais que cette pensée tu la
détailles il y a aucune raison de de tu
vois quand je dis que Sabrina de boys
boys boys tout était axé là-dessus dans
les années 80 tu la vois sortir une
piscine avec un t-shirt collant c'était
globalement plus ça que sa musique pour
lesquelles les gens et alors
je suis une femme je suis italienne
sablée un salaire très connu en Italie
et bah et encore aujourd'hui
il fait très peu de choses
comme ça et surtout je peux dire un truc
elle a joué beaucoup sur ça mais oui
tous ces vidéos et tout sa carrière elle
est tournée sur ça donc
après aujourd'hui on doit mettre de on
doit se boucher la bouche pour beaucoup
de choses mais il a pas dit un truc ni
sexiste ni autre chose c'est un peu la
vérité oui il y a aujourd'hui une autre
femme très connue en Italie s'appelle
Lamborghini voilà que c'est la fille
petite fille de Lamborghini qui est
aussi elle et jour sur son physique et
fait passer des chansons et même aller
au festival de saint-rémond mais il faut
dire aussi que il joue beaucoup sur son
physique donc il y a des des femmes et
aussi des hommes des hommes qui sont
joués sur physique qui marchaient mieux
que leur talent moi j'ai fait carrière
grâce à ça
bon ben j'avais ce truc là avantageux je
me suis comment je vais pouvoir faire
l'amour vous êtes caché tout à l'heure
horloge
maintenant j'ai des enfants je suis plus
sur le marché c'est bon vous êtes réunis
tous ensemble vous me faites les
présentations de vos trois partenaires
alors je suis obligé de le faire dans le
désordre et sans préférence puisque je
les aime tous les trois beaucoup pour
des raisons tout à fait diverses et
variées le plus ancien je parle
évidemment pas de Michel qui est à la
fois mon produit
c'est le patron de la Madeleine c'est
aussi mon producteur et mon manager donc
c'est quelqu'un de très important dans
ma vie professionnelle et avec qui je
suis marié depuis 10 ans et je suis
marié heureux donc c'est plutôt cool tu
vois après dans dans d'un point de vue
stricto sensu artistique Adrien c'est
comme un petit frère c'est un mec j'ai
eu la chance le bon Dieu l'a mis sur ma
route il y a il y a un peu plus de 6 ans
maintenant quand vous avez envoyé un
invitation ouais c'était même mieux que
ça il est venu me voir un dîner un soir
en me disant j'aime beaucoup ce que vous
faites vous m'avez je m'arrête si je
travaille tes propos mais quand j'ai vu
boire fumer conduire vite vous de donner
envie de faire du théâtre et voilà j'ai
écrit ça et je l'ai lu et j'ai trouvé ça
merveilleux et je me suis battu pour que
ça existe maintenant ça existe et c'est
un type avec qui d'avoir j'ai plein
d'atomes crochus pour mille raisons il
est mes enfants l'adorent il est
maintenant c'est pareil il fait partie
de la famille mais artistiquement j'ai
l'impression de comprendre ce qu'il
écrit c'est à dire que quand il m'écrit
des personnages je sais ce qu'il veut
avoir je sais ce qu'il a envie de voir
je sais ce qu'il entend quand il écrit
je crois donc donc c'est un vrai bonheur
de bosser avec ce mec évidemment il est
bourré de talent et c'est toujours mieux
de travailler des gens non c'est pas
vrai 55 mais il est cache bien
vous dites pour vous philippez Lellouche
c'est la référence quoi pour les
pas la référence
si si moi je
j'étais un peu déprimé tu sais je me dis
bon j'arriverai pas j'arriverai pas à
faire du théâtre j'arriverai pas ça moi
je vois pas et je suis passé voir vite
et en sortant je me suis [ __ ] c'est
c'est vraiment fou j'avais ri j'avais
pleuré à la fin ça m'avait bouleversé ça
je me dis [ __ ] donc en fait je
comprends que ce que j'ai envie de faire
ça peut être sur une scène et ça peut
avoir du succès ça a été pleine les gens
étaient debout à la fin je me disais ok
donc ce que j'ai envie de faire ça peut
ok je crois ça me parlait vraiment et
donc c'est vrai quand je rentrais
Philippe c'est quoi une soirée qui était
pas la plus simple pour moi et on s'est
parlé ça m'a c'était génial c'était
super
on continue on continue
Aline c'est c'est un choix c'est une
comédienne un jour dont Frédéric belle
me parle en me disant le plus grand bien
et je regarde son profil je la trouve
très bien et qu'en Francis s'interroge
et qui cherche une une femme qui
ressemble
un personnage qui ressemble à celui qui
pouvait interpréter à Line je lui dis en
prenant tous les risques voilà
elle me paraît très bien mais je suis
pas capable de décider elle a été voir
Francis Veber elle a passé son casting
comme une grande et Francis m'a rappelé
et Francis m'a dit c'est exactement le
personnage merci Philippe ce qu'on
appelle un coup de pot et quand elle est
arrivée sur scène elle a elle a avec moi
elle a les qualités attends 2 secondes
je vais m'interrompre pardonne-moi à
Lille oui
bien pimenté mais il sait le patron
c'est l'huile d'olive ail et piment
et vous qu'est-ce que vous préférez et
vous savez comment je vais vous suivre
pareil
[Musique]
c'est hyper impressionnant
moi je vais prendre le foie gras
là c'est pas possible
vous pouvez pas faire la viande avec les
pâtes à côté les gars c'est pas possible
ah bah non non c'est interdit là en
Italie les gars
non c'est interdit vous comprenez pas
c'est interdit si je prends les seuls
c'est hors de question je ne veux pas
les pâtes
[Musique]
tout le monde a choisi
du rouge non
plus
de patron
je pourrais en parler plein d'heures
parce que c'est une comédienne qui qui
est une self-medwomen qui a fait tout un
tas de pièces qui est passé par le café
théâtre etc et cas naturellement ce que
je disais tout à l'heure la viscomica
c'est-à-dire que ça c'est le truc
malheureusement qui est qui s'apprend
pas dans n'importe quel cours de théâtre
c'est de la chance c'est le sens du
rythme c'est le sens de la musique
presque et qui comprend en quel rythme
il faut faire et surtout elle a une
qualité essentielle le talent c'est
infiniment respectable mais le talent
sans travail c'est pissé dans un violon
et c'est une grosse travailleuse c'est à
dire qu'elle est elle est en demande en
permanence de bosser d'apprendre de
faire et le résultat bah il est
forcément à la clé parce que elle ménage
pas son effort et s'agit pas ça parce
qu'elle est là c'est parce que vraiment
je le pense c'est une formidable non
mais c'est une formidable actrice et je
sais que
cette histoire pour elle et qu'un départ
parce que je pense que c'est quelqu'un
il y a quelqu'un qui s'inquiète sur son
avenir
ça se passe quand un peu comme ça
c'était vraiment j'ai envoyé donc c'est
Frédéric
non j'envoie mon CV
au téléphone star vendredi donc je suis
tout tremblante il me dit bon tu lis le
texte et on s'appelle ce soir donc le
soir il me rappelle en visio il dit
aussi un morceau du test quand même et
là maintenant tout de suite là ok bon et
vous de 5 minutes il me fait bon tu as
compris le personnage et tout tu vas
rentrer le lendemain Weber chez lui donc
Weber m'appelle et il m'a dit voici mon
adresse
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et moi j'arrive j'avais imprimé le texte
la veille au soir et vous avez appris
par coeur toute la nuit mon rôle j'avais
passé la nuit à prendre en disant si je
repasse un essai je faut que j'apprenne
faut que j'aille passer la nuit à
prendre et je suis arrivée m'a parlé du
personnage comment il le voyait etc et
au bout d'un moment j'ai fait vous
voulez que je vous fasse un morceau il
m'a dit non mais je veux voir votre
personnalité et tout et on a parlé de
moi mon parcours et voilà après il m'a
dit bon je vous laisse et puis c'est une
heure après c'est Michel qui m'a appelé
en me disant je me souviens cette phrase
je sais pas ce que vous avez fait
Francis le blog
voilà félicitations j'ai dit un truc que
moi c'est pas c'est surtout mais je dis
un truc sur la ligne qui est pas
beaucoup d'attrist il a eu le courage de
jamais s'arrêter et elle envoie elle
envoie elle a envoyé les CV en disant on
est de toute façon il va manger mais
elle essaye elle est tente et tous les
les comédies ne font pas ça ils ont
beaucoup dans l'attendais elle elle
fonce elle est plein d'énergie elle
écrit elle fait des documentaire des
petits des trucs et ça arrête jamais
parce que pour vous c'est pour vous deux
par exemple c'est plus simple enfin
[Musique]
elle a pas peur et ça c'est génial parce
que c'est il y a vraiment un plein
d'énergie et elle essaye et c'est ça
qu'il faut absolument arriver à percer
et de beaucoup de comédiens ils savent
pas quoi faire qu'est-ce qu'il faut que
je ferme mais vas-y il tente ils ont pas
le courage et donc il faut pas avoir
juste les talents comédie la beauté
qu'elle aille tout ça mais aussi cette
force énergie incroyable c'était
vraiment très fort chaque jour il m'a
dit je fais ça je fais ça j'écris j'ai
refait ça elle est vraiment très forte
c'est la force elle a la force de tu
vois parce qu'on parlait de de des
femmes tout à l'heure c'est c'est ce que
je respecte le plus infiniment chez les
femmes elles ont cette force courage que
parfois beaucoup d'hommes n'ont pas tu
vois donc c'est c'est c'est c'est je
suis avec deux nanas qui sont qui sont
des femmes comment pour dire ça poliment
tout en étant vulgaire des femmes qui
ont des couilles voilà et elles sont
elles sont formidables elles sont jolies
elles sont talentueuses elles bossent
elles sont gentilles c'est la
gentillesse est quand même une qualité
aujourd'hui essentielle j'arrive oui
merci beaucoup monsieur et pour arriver
à Caterina alors Katerina on se on se
connaît depuis quelques années mais sans
se connaître on se croise on a toujours
eu de très bons rapports et j'adore
cette comédienne je la trouve intense je
la trouve vraie et et et plus on la
connaît plus on se dit que la première
impression était très en dessous de la
réalité c'est que c'est quelqu'un de de
d'intenses qui fait pas semblant de vous
aimer quand elle vous prend la main elle
vous prend la main quand elle joue elle
joue elle vous regarde quand elle pleure
elle pleure c'est une italienne en même
temps sur le plat de pâtes
elle a des coupures sur des trucs des
fois bon elle appelle son mari à peu
près 653 fois par jour et nous nous
surprend je sais pas comment le mec
tient ça et il tient donc et puis et
puis c'est une comédienne qui s'était
illustrée dans
plutôt dans plein de choses assez peu
dans la comédie à ma connaissance et
elle-même avait des doutes c'est
toujours les gens les plus talentueux
qui ont le plus de doute et elle est
merveilleuse parce que parce qu'elle
joue exactement comme j'aime c'est à
dire que je déteste les gens qui jouent
comédie quand on joue on une comédie on
doit jouer vrai et c'est ça qui est
drôle tu joues comédie en montrant que
ce que tu vas faire est drôle c'est
souvent chiant et elle joue intensément
j'ai un peu comme pour prendre un autre
italien que j'aime par-dessus tout
l'inventura il jouait espion lève-toi ou
qui joue de l'aventure c'est l'aventure
il joue de la même façon mais ça marche
dans les deux cas et elle fait partie de
ces gens donc en fait cette bande là bon
alors Adrien c'est même plus c'est
évident mais avec Katerina et Aline j'ai
j'ai ces gens avec lesquels en fait moi
j'ai un problème c'est c'est que quand
je commence à jouer avec des gens et que
je m'attache j'ai envie de faire 10 ans
avec eux quoi donc
la pièce probablement pas parce que
d'abord on aurait pas envie de la jouer
10 ans mais la troupe qui joue cette
pièce oui
Adrien
est-ce que ça vous énerve d'ailleurs
qu'on parle on parle de ce rôle tout le
temps parce que
[Musique]
ça aura toujours moi alors il y a deux
choses avec Daniel Craig c'était une
expérience extraordinaire dans tout la
famille bande bien sûr ma carrière
surtout internationale a explosé et tu
dois toujours
remercier
[Musique]
pour ce rôle avec tout les femmes au
monde qui aurait pu prendre
j'ai appris beaucoup de trucs sur la
sous la professionnalité sur la sur les
voyages dans les mondes sur la presse
tout ça mais ce que j'ai appris avec ce
monsieur
peut-être pas après avec avec Daniel
parce que Daniel c'est un rôle qui était
dans mes cordes bien sûr c'était plus
simple
mais c'est vrai que donc on va dire que
le rôle de serrage depuis dans mes
cordes comme a dit Philippe je suis plus
dans le dans le rôle dramatique et dans
le rôle un peu plus quotidien dramatique
ce qui m'a pris Philippe c'est la
comédie et je le remercierai jamais
assez parce que parce que déjà pour moi
la triste de théâtre italien je suis
vraiment tous les plus beaux et plus
grands théâtre en Italie je vais pas
encore vraiment mis pied dans les
théâtre en France par une pièce Médée en
Corse mais donc merci à Michel et à
Philippe parce que j'ai quand même
débuté au théâtre à la Madeleine que
c'est beau théâtre de Paris avec
Philippe dans la pièce de Francis Gobert
donc pour moi c'est une immense cadeau
et donc voilà entre Daniel et lui il
m'avait faire un immense début dans
l'Internet final et Philippe un immense
début dans le théâtre en France qui pour
moi c'est très très cher et il m'a pris
il m'a pris il m'a pris la comédie et
surtout m'a pris aussi que quand les
gens rigolent il faut
mais qu'est-ce que de toute façon en
même temps ça va être assez vite
merci Monsieur
comment tu peux dire autre chose
au plaisir d'être ensemble
santé bonheur santé bonheur
nous tous il y a personne de focus
[Musique]
après j'ai des choses à dire sur
Philippe
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise
d'autre que c'est pour moi le plus grand
acteur de France j'en suis fier mais tu
peux pas imaginer c'est mon petit frère
c'est vraiment peut-être le plus grand
acteur mais je le pense je dis pas que
pour moi je le pense vraiment et
c'est mon petit frère et j'en suis hyper
fier et je l'aime donc une fois que tu
as dit ça qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
te rajoute sur mon frère tu vois c'est
que c'est une fierté permanente voilà et
puis et puis et puis je vais même te
dire ça me a double titre parce que non
seulement je suis fier de mon frère en
tant que un peu ou je me suis frère
Pierre de mon frère pour mon père qui
n'est plus et qui je sais serait
tellement heureux de voir tout ce qui
nous arrive donc il y a un moment où je
tu vois la conversation va
on peut tout ce que tu veux mais j'ai
dit là l'essentiel et ce qui va revenir
à peu près dans toutes les phrases si tu
me poses la question vous avez des trois
vous pourriez faire des trucs ensemble
derrière comment ça se fait que vous
faites c'est rare faites le même boulot
c'est fou vous avez voulu faire il vous
a suivi ou non ça c'est fait
mais différent c'est pas là vous faites
pas la même chose
on fait le même métier mais on l'exerce
pas au même endroit c'est-à-dire que
pour l'instant c'est vrai que Gilles est
au cinéma je ne doute pas qu'il aura
envie d'un jour aller au théâtre et moi
je fais assez peu de cinéma
pour une raison assez simple c'est que
d'abord je suis tellement au théâtre que
c'est très compliqué de caler un film
quand tu joues pendant des mois et des
mois au théâtre voilà maintenant il y a
une chose qui est sûr c'est que je suis
moins demandé par effet que mon frère au
cinéma et ça va très bien et c'est super
vous pourriez faire des trucs ensemble
ou pas j'adorerais on fait peur
un jour c'est évident c'est toujours dit
qu'un jour on aimerait bien faire un
film tous les deux mais c'est très
compliqué
par ça au cours de théâtre Florent et
ailleurs mais mais il est très accaparé
par le théâtre je parle aussi donc le
rôle idéal en fait un film ensemble là
faudrait jouer deux frères parce que
c'est difficile de faire croire qu'on va
jouer autre chose que deux frères
d'abord parce que je crois que
physiquement plutôt pas mal il faudrait
que ce soit une comédie ou alors un truc
vraiment ou alors faut que ce soit non
les deux qui jouent ensemble ils vont
rigoler chaque épisode
on a fait un film ensemble il y a 15 ans
un film de d'un copain qui s'appelle
Tristan rouet qu'une copain dans le sens
de mon frère
qui était un film pas drôle du tout mais
nous on avait des scènes de comédie on a
passé notre temps à se marrer je vois
mon frère jouer je ris et réciproquement
donc on faisait deux frères gitans vont
être moins abrutis et c'est vrai que ça
tourne vite en crise de forêt
tout le temps mais bien sûr je sais pas
il est obligé j'imagine il est à droite
à gauche mais quand il est à Paris
régulièrement et puis là on va faire
Noël chez ma mère oui non on est très
proche très très proche heureusement
c'est une autre façon de ma mère nous
taperait
deux frères vous êtes pas né en France
non je suis dans Israël et lui il est
assez vite sur orge et vous vous êtes
franco-israinien vous êtes non je suis
je suis français
j'ai pas
j'ai pas de je suis pas franco-israelien
je comprends rien à la vie en Israël ça
m'intéresse assez peu enfin ça
m'intéresse tout autant que la vieille
si ta question et est-ce que tu te sens
juif je suis juif mais pas israélien je
suis français juif
voilà
donc je sais pas vous dites ça comme
s'il fallait c'est un truc qu'on affirme
c'est un truc qu'on affirme parce que
dans la question et pardonne-moi si je
l'ai mal comprise mais dans la question
il y a je sais ce qui vient derrière
parce que c'est souvent le cas c'est à
dire que Israël était franco-israélien
mais alors c'est quoi tes cité Israël tu
vas tu vas arriver sur Israël qu'est-ce
que tu penses d'Israël et tout ça et je
m'en branle je peux pas te dire autre
chose je me fous complètement de ce qui
se passe en Israël comme je me fous de
ce qui se passe en ce moment à Lisbonne
ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qui se passe
dans mon pays si maintenant la question
sous-jacente est ce que tu es juif oui à
moitié et catholique de ma mère mais je
suis juif dans mon cœur et et mes
français avant tout c'est-à-dire que moi
je suis absolument un patriote
franchouillard absolu c'est à dire que
je je j'aime ce pays qui m'a tout donné
et à qui je dois tout parce que c'est ma
langue parce que c'est mon esprit parce
que dès que je sens à l'étranger je me
sens franchement
idiot je me dis ah c'est mieux en France
la bouffe est meilleure je suis un peu
un beau
j'ai toujours peur de de j'ai toujours
peur de se mélanges des gens parce qu'il
y a plein plein de gens qui considèrent
que c'est l'appellation israélite qui
finalement était une appellation
inventée par les antisémites pour pas
dire juifs comme c'est un gros mot donc
israélite Israël et on a toujours
l'impression que si on est né en Israël
aussi on israélien alors on n'est pas
vraiment français enfin tu vois tout ce
truc qui me qui me chagrine terriblement
parce que je suis d'abord un citoyen du
monde juive de confession de coeur et
d'esprit mais mais mais mon drapeau il
est bleu blanc rouge
à un imbécile qui m'appelait qui disait
franco-israélien sioniste etc ce qui est
absolument insupportable c'est-à-dire
que c'est c'est mais là on est dans On
est tu vois c'est ce que tu dis
aujourd'hui tu crois que tu dises tu vas
faire une vanne sur Twitter il y a un
mec au fin fond de la Bretagne qui veut
dire que tu l'as faite pour moi la vanne
on voit que tu disais
je fais une vanne si elle te plaît pas
vas-y passe à autre chose la même chose
quand un mec me dit il défend son copain
Eric Dupond-Moretti ce sioniste machin
film était fou en fait je suis
passionniste je m'en fous je je suis pas
alors c'est pas vrai
je m'en fous pas
aujourd'hui on sait plus qui veut dire
je pense que cela veut dire non
c'est quoi sioniste aujourd'hui c'est
c'est que c'est la reconnaissance de
l'État d'Israël voilà point
tu reconnais Israël en ce sens là je
suis sioniste je reconnais l'État
d'Israël voilà comme je reconnais le
Portugal comme je reconnais la Suède
comme je reconnais l'Algérie que
française et que c'est algérienne pardon
je pense que les gens crèvent de
petits partis pris qui n'ont pas lieu
d'être en fait moi aujourd'hui je pense
que d'abord on est les citoyens du monde
que j'en ai ras-le-bol de mais au même
titre que ça peut me choquer quand je
vois des drapeaux pour un oui pour un
nom qui sont pas les en France qui sont
pas les drapeaux français tu dis à un
moment on vit dans un pays qui est
merveilleux qui donne un libre accès à
tout à la religion à la double culture à
la triple culture etc c'est il est cool
ce pays j'en ai marre de d'entendre des
gens Bacher la France ou la trahir voilà
je serai jamais du côté des des gens
extrêmes qui pensent que français c'est
absolument un truc essentiel non on s'en
fout mettez français tu aimes ton pays
ça veut pas dire que tu aimes pas les
autres et ça veut pas dire que tu vas
tomber dans les extrêmes comme j'ai vu
pour les cités Zemmour ou Le Pen etc ce
sera jamais ma tasse de thé je ne peux
pas je ne pourrai jamais moi j'aime tous
les Français voilà y compris ceux qui
sont basés et ceux qui sont noirs
bah je trouve qu'un artiste qui fait de
la politique c'est vite chiant c'est pas
notre boulot nous on est là pour faire
pour distraire les gens faut être sacré
vous avez des idées c'est obligatoire
ouais mais tu les gardes pour toi parce
que ces idées là elles sont bonnes à
exprimer dans un cercle familial elles
sont pas moi les gens les gens qui
aiment bien Philippe Lellouche j'espère
qu'il me regarde c'est pas des gens qui
ont envie de me voir m'exprimer sur une
opinion politique qui n'engage que moi
et qui en plus sera mal étayé parce que
c'est pas mon boulot et je prétends pas
donner des leçons aux gens moi moi le
seul truc qui m'intéresse c'est de les
faire rire ou de les faire pleurer de
les distraire mon boulot c'est de
distraire les gens c'est certainement
pas de leur dire comment il faut penser
parce que vous avez un copain qui fait
de la police ah ouais bah oui mais c'est
son métier lui c'est autre chose puis il
était avocat tu vois il est ministre
mais d'abord
non mais Eric Éric il est Eric il est
légitime d'abord parce que quand tu as
été avocat d'être garde des sceaux ça
fait sens parce que ça m'intéresse qui
annonce pas c'est bien c'est bon
toute seule avant la viande et après il
y a la viande mais pas ensemble déjà
je suis très fier de mon copain c'est
pareil tu vois j'ai eu la chance
parce que c'est moi qui l'a mis en scène
tu te souviens
et c'est Adrien qui a des coécrit
ça fait quoi d'avoir non mais pour moi
est-il impressionnant ou pas après c'est
notre ami si oui bien sûr rien
d'incroyable la première fois que vous
le voyez il est quand même
quelqu'un de très de très intelligent
très charismatique de très généreux non
c'est quelqu'un à moi que j'admire
beaucoup et c'est vrai qu'on est très
fier de lui c'est incroyable
[Musique]
et je trouve tout à fait légitime que le
plus grand avocat de France devienne
garde des sceaux ça me choque pas c'est
pas comme si tu mets moi demain garde
des sceaux là on peut se dire il y a un
truc qui va pas tu vois et encore et
encore
[Musique]
ministre de la Culture
il y a des trucs d'ailleurs je me
souviens du soir où il a été élu BFM
m'appelle moi tu vois donc je demande
d'avoir l'autorisation à lui je peux pas
le joindre parce qu'il est dans le
tourbillon de
de de de de de la domination de
l'annonce donc j'appelle sa femme je dis
est-ce que je peux parler à midi mais
Éric sera ravi c'est toi qui parle et
donc je me souviens que c'était brush
tout ça qui m'avait interviewé qui
m'avait dit qu'est-ce que ça fait
d'avoir votre copain garde des sceaux la
seule le seul truc que j'ai répondu et
qui était le plus sincère c'est-à-dire
écouter déjà quand on est un pote qui
est délégué de classe on est content
c'est un pote qui a gardé ça tu vois
voilà tu vois c'est merci infiniment
huile d'olive ail et piment simple c'est
hyper simple et c'est super bon c'est ce
que les Italiens
elle a une bûche
et toi vous avez pris quoi à vous
tu manges pas humilité
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
en fonction de ta notoriété tu peux
avoir un pourcentage sur le remplissage
voilà où est le coproducteur ce qui
arrive aussi à certains artistes de
temps en temps voilà de vouloir
coproduire la pièce mais c'est un risque
et péril ça si ça marche pas pour le
coup ça coûte alors que j'étais au
pourcentage tu peux gagner moins mais tu
peux pas de rien gagner du tout voilà
vous vous sentez si ça va marcher ou pas
avant est-ce qu'il y a des choses vous
êtes partis sur des projets vous dites
là je le sens pas bien sûr enfin quand
tu pars sur un projet sauf quand t'as
pas le choix c'est-à-dire quand tu es
môme quand tu débutes tu prends tout ce
qu'on me donne tu vois c'est
après quand tu as un peu de bouteille tu
choisis un peu tes projets et quand tu
les choisis c'est que tu y crois
mais
oui
merci beaucoup
ça nous a pas de sens
monsieur vous avez une critique sur
votre plat tout à l'heure
en italien
plat est très bon mais vous savez très
bien que on mange pas la viande avec les
pâtes c'est fait pour les Français c'est
fait pour les Français oui mais
vous trahi vous créez une entreprise
c'est la trahison
milanaise mais avec une salade sucrée
vous croyez que tous les jours
qu'elle est fatiguant ils vont pas
manger avec la viande
il va mettre critiquer évidemment qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup d'italien malgré que
des Français
c'est le meilleur restaurant de Paris je
le dis et je le répète c'est le meilleur
italien de Paris
bon appétit
ouais quand vous parlez avec du
commandant systémique je sais pas si
votre copain mais je vous vois chez Anna
c'est mon ami
la même ambiance quoi ah ben non c'est
pas
en fait je oui après c'est je sais pas
si je suis tout terrain en fait
et Philippe Lellouche c'est pas les
mêmes quoi
vous qui nous regardez sur Youtube je
vous laisse ce garçon un mauvais fond
voilà c'est tout
non
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise en
fait tu penses ça ils ont des œufs je
vous vois pas faire vos blagues
tu vois pas faire mes glaces quoi faire
les blagues chez Hanouna du 1er mais si
c'est bon il adore exactement
en fait c'est pas c'est tu tu implique
leurs opinions politiques ou leurs
opinions
leurs opinions sociales voilà dans la
vie je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
fondamentalement différent c'est deux
types à leur mettre encore une fois avec
deux personnalités différentes
extrêmement généreux extrêmement fidèle
avec leurs amis drôle etc après quand tu
opposes moi je peux avoir un copain qui
est de gauche ou un copain qui est de
droite il s'entendent pas politiquement
mais en dehors de ça c'est des mecs
absolument adorables les deux
ou droite mais je m'en fous je m'en fous
ce qui m'apporte pour moi c'est que de
voir des gens heureux et j'ai
l'impression que dans notre pays on a
tout pour être heureux de s'échapper qui
disait les Français sont des gens qui
vivent au paradis en étant persuadé
qu'ils sont en enfer
et je suis d'accord avec ça c'est-à-dire
qu'en ce moment je pense qu'il faut
plutôt parler de réunification des gens
et moi à ma modeste façon j'essaye de le
faire en les faisant rire tous de la
même façon plutôt que cette espèce de
de volonté de scinder la population en
communauté en communauté d'idées etc
alors que finalement on est tous les
mêmes et que et qu'on a qu'une envie
c'est de kiffer on a qu'une vie une
seule supposément [ __ ] si on de la
vive bien quoi tu vois j'ai plutôt envie
de me marrer moi que de me faire chier à
discuter sur un truc qui
fondamentalement changeront pas tu vois
à peu près tout tout me fait marrer
d'abord tout ce qui m'énerve finit par
me faire rire tu vois c'est à dire que
je m'arrange pour tourner tout ce qui
m'emmerde en rigolade mais tout me fait
rire c'est à dire que d'abord c'est une
obsession toute la journée tous les
matins
je me dis qu'est-ce qu'il va me faire
marrer aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que j'ai
vraiment envie de faire
moi de rien c'est une prof facile parce
que je sais que je vais il a eu sur
scène voilà donc dès que je fais une
connerie varier mais j'arrive à me faire
rire tout seul on est sur le faire rire
c'est complètement débile
de visage donc ça c'est un truc que je
faisais avec mon frère quand elle était
petit ma grand-mère
Los Angeles voilà j'ai trahi ton œuvre
non mais c'est important vous êtes sûr
il y a un truc il y a un truc déjà fou
c'est que nous on dit
on va jouer on dit jamais on va
travailler donc aujourd'hui on va jouer
tu vois c'est non mais il y a jamais
mangé
un quart d'heure avant je vais te dire
j'ai pas envie d'y aller quoi
absolument vous en faites deux
on arrive sur scène
on respecte tous les soirs
le documentaire d'Al Pacino qui montre
la fabrication de régions 3 avec une una
rider c'est passionnant parce que
justement il raconte que Shakespeare
Molière ou Francis Weber papa
exactement
et jouer différemment
après on s'ennuie on n'a pas et donc le
public ça marche pas donc on est obligé
de sortir une nouveauté même quand il y
a un texte hyper précis et surtout ça
réinventer ce qu'on dit parce que si on
dit toujours à plat parce que ça rentre
robotique
une bonne histoire dont tu es fière tu
vas la raconter 20 fois 20 potes
différents tu auras jamais tu auras
jamais l'impression de te répéter parce
que tu sais que pour celui qui t'écoute
c'est la première fois donc tu vas
jubiler du plaisir que tu vas lui donner
à la fin en riant et ben le théâtre
c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire que
tous les soirs tu vois bien que tu
racontes aux gens un truc qui
connaissent pas donc à nouveau tu te
réinvente
et entre nous aussi parce que dès le
début
c'est pas bien enfin vous connaissez
mais pas sur scène vous y allez oui mais
vous allez dire dès le premier soir vous
vous sentez de aller en commun ou non
quand même hein
premier soir
c'est après que tu commences à prendre
des libertés mais le premier soir en
général tu fais tout bien
rentré tu es arrivé
mais c'est pas possible elle était
génial
bonté autant être aussi libre et être
aussi au tombeau comédien et il n'est
pas inconvénient donc
on a découvert vraiment un comédien
extraordinaire
et pas jouer dans un grand tatouage par
la déplace pardon excuse-moi vas-y
c'est un plaisir moi je suis je suis
ravi c'est super c'est une super
expérience
et je trouve ça génial d'avoir justement
la liberté de pouvoir inventer tous les
soirs de chercher de progresser
une salle qui rit c'est fou quoi je
trouve ça génial c'est jouissif pour
franchement c'est un régal en fait
c'est le seul moment dans la dans la
journée où tu es peinard il y a une
vieille comédienne que j'adore vieille
étant pas un terme péjoratif du tout et
qui nous a quitté quelques années que
j'adorais qui Maria Pacôme qui m'avait
dit quand j'étais môme quand tu joues au
théâtre ta journée est foutue voilà et
c'est vrai toute ta journée du réveil tu
calcules tout ce que tu fais en fonction
de ta représentation du soir donc tu
fais pas d'excès tu fais pas du sport à
partir de quelle heure tu as ta tête ta
journée les conditionner interprétation
du soir là là alors on est c'est le
moment on est peinard c'est bon on a
joué
dès que ça s'arrête d'un seul coup il y
a le truc de ouais c'est ça c'est fini
tu vois pas forcément physique mais il y
a un truc c'est une montée d'adrénaline
évidente on n'arrive pas à dormir tout
de suite
le matin tôt donc je suis obligé de
faire dodo et c'est très compliqué parce
que avec ma définition c'est compliqué
vous habitez tous à Paris
moi j'habite à la campagne
pour moi Paris c'est le bureau voilà
c'est un beau bureau mais c'est le
bureau donc le soir j'ai besoin de la
campagne j'ai besoin d'arriver de passer
la cuvette de l'Essonne là de me faire
ça y est je suis au calme donc tu vois
c'est c'est mais tu sais en fait j'ai
pas une vie
du touche au business moi des gens
s'attendaient ça un peu mais c'est une
star
de il est non mais copains sont
évidemment il y a Eric Gérard Darmon il
y a des potes très intimes qui font ce
métier Adrien mais j'ai
mes potes sont mes copains d'enfance que
je connais que depuis que j'ai 15 ans et
avec qui je passe le plus clair de mon
temps et c'est presque une c'est une
vraie sécurité pour moi c'est c'est je
vais me dire c'est un garde-fou c'est ça
me connecte en permanence avec ce que je
suis avec les gens etc et j'ai pas envie
de je suis pas de show business tu vois
avant il était avant il était un peu
près
où il fait le plein d'oseille
ou pas bien sûr
[Musique]
mais bon
c'est une relou
je préférais qu'il était avant
[Rires]
c'est quoi tes origines toi
j'ai grandi à Annecy et j'ai de la
famille africaine
mec il vient du bled il croit que
pourtant je suis français je suis quoi
ben oui tu es français frérot mais on
voit que tu as des origines du bled
c'est pour ça que le piquant ça doit pas
te faire peur
italien
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est quoi la suite parce que tout à
l'heure Michel m'a montré une pièce sur
votre
sur votre bureau dans la loge
de te tuer et donc ça va se faire cette
histoire
qui fait comme ça avec la tête il va se
faire bientôt c'est un Italien alors ça
c'est toi qui raconte
deux ans il y a 7 ans il y a 6 ans parce
que on peut toujours 2 ans et c'est une
pièce magnifique qui a été écrit par
John Carla madrina
qui a 45 ans et qui a qui est directeur
maintenant de un des plus beaux théâtre
au monde s'appelle théâtre olive
et donc c'est c'est l'histoire
d'un PM ça veut dire le public ministère
en Italie mais là on a transformé voilà
on a transformé en juge instruction qui
est appelé à minuit pour interroger un
homme qui viennent les fracasser la tête
de sa femme et donc pendant toute la
nuit on va entendre
obligatoirement parce que lui il va il
va pas m'avouer tout de suite qu'il a
tué cette femme on va entendre enfin la
version
de comment s'est passé son divorce et
moi je suis en plein de gorge et je vais
juste défoncer cet homme qui est
horrible c'est un diable qu'il est
homophobe qui appelle sa femme [ __ ]
pendant tout le long de la pièce et qui
est dégueulasse dans tous les Francs et
moi je vais tout le monde tout le monde
a mis juste de monter sur scène les
fracasser il arrive avec un chemise
tachée de sang dans la tête de sa femme
et c'est sa fille de 10 ans qui a appelé
les flics et puis tu habitais on va
découvrir la vérité de ce qui se passe
et je me rends compte que la justice
c'est la pas donc mes collègues ils ont
pas vraiment fait le travail qui aurait
dû faire et on va découvrir une autre
vérité que je vais pas vous dire non
certainement pas vous attendre en avril
et donc c'est c'est une autre version de
de de ce place alors je ne vais pas
parler des féminicides je n'ai pas parlé
de ça une des raisons pour laquelle
junkarl a mis en scène cette pièce et
c'est une vraie histoire à part la
meurtre le meurtre de la de la femme
c'est une vraie histoire c'est un ami à
lui qui a vécu cette affaire c'est aussi
raconté l'autre côté parce qu'il y a pas
seulement les femmes victimes et aussi
des hommes sous victimes pendant les
divorce et que ce qu'on voudrait avoir à
la fin de cette pièce c'est que la
justice il peut se mettre aussi en
question que les parents parfaite et on
le sait et peut-être notre cher ministre
Dupont-Moretti pourrait aussi nous aider
par rapport à ça parce que de temps en
temps et de plus en plus je voudrais et
on voudrait que la justice arrête de
juger une femme contre un homme mais il
faudrait juger un être humain contre un
être humain et jugé seulement le fait
et malheureusement ça arrive pas très
souvent et donc cette pièce c'est mettre
en valeur les erreurs que la justice est
fait et raconter une autre vérité qui
est pas vraiment très entendu
c'est génial c'est super c'est très bien
écrit elle a proposé à James et moi je
l'ai pris et qui va jouer alors
l'homme horrible qui a tué sa femme et
Aline Gayo il fera un greffière ah donc
on reste sur cette
malheureusement il n'y a pas de rôle
pour Adrien donc il aura Patrice balotta
qui fera un avocat Douglas
si vous voulez
donc là je sais pas le nom des familles
incroyable et Victoria
ma mère et on a tous du piment peut-être
c'est un bon sujet et j'ai vu que c'est
Christophe
Barbier l'a traduit avec moi donc moi
j'ai traduisait petit cochon
la mise en scène et donc on fera le
spectacle au Théâtre Madeleine en avril
et en septembre-octobre on ira à théâtre
pour la jouer c'est pour ça tout à
l'heure en septembre
en italien
je suis un acteur qui travaille
j'apprends l'italien
c'est pas grave
il est
les mecs de chez nous on peut pas les
changer
plus jamais tu deviendras jamais c'est
trop tard c'est dans tes veines mais moi
j'ai cru je te jure que je me suis dit
c'est Christophe j'ai cru ah j'ai dit
c'est des gens Tristan très sérieux
c'était le film il est très sérieux
quoi ça parle c'est vous
business
regarde ton fils ça y est il est chez
nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ta mère
tu as vu chérie il a essayé de cacher
mais ils l'ont vu
la caméra pourquoi
[Rires]
raconter n'importe quoi je vous